Let us now discuss
in some more detail
what it takes to carry
out Bayesian inference,
when both random
variables are discrete.
The unknown parameter,
Theta, is a random variable
that takes values
in the discrete set.
And we can think of these values
as alternative hypotheses.
In this case, we know
how to do inference.
We have in our
hands the Bayes rule
and we have seen
plenty of examples.
So instead of going through
one more example in detail,
let us assume that we have a
model, that we have observed
the value of X, and that
we have already determined
the conditional PMF of
the random variable Theta.
As a concrete example,
suppose that Theta
can take values 1, 2, or 3.
We have obtained
our observation,
and the conditional
PMF takes this form.
We could stop at
this point or we
could continue by asking for
a specific estimate of Theta--
our best guess as
to what Theta is.
One way of coming
up with an estimate
is to use the maximum a
posteriori of probability
rule, which looks for
that value of theta that
has the largest posterior,
or conditional, probability.
In this example,
it is this value,
so our estimate is
going to be equal to 2.
An alternative way of
coming up with an estimate
could be the LMS
rule, which calculates
an estimate equal to the
conditional expectation
of the unknown parameter,
given the observation that we
have made.
This is just the mean of this
conditional distribution.
In this example, it would
fall somewhere around here,
and the numerical value, as
you can check, is equal to 2.2.
Next, we may be interested in
how good a certain estimate is.
And for the case where we
interpret the values of Theta
as hypotheses, a
relevant criterion
is the probability of error.
In this case, because
we already have
some data available
in our hands and we're
called to make an estimate,
what we care about
is the conditional probability,
given the information
that we have, that
we're making an error.
Making an error
means the following.
We have the observation,
the value of the estimate
has been determined,
it is now a number,
and that's why we write it
with a lowercase theta hat.
But the parameter
is still unknown.
We don't know what it is.
It is described by
this distribution.
And there's a
probability that it's
going to be different
from our estimate.
What is this probability?
It depends on how we
construct the estimates.
If in this example,
we use the MAP rule
and we make an
estimate of 2, there
is probability 0.6 that
the true value of Theta
is also equal to
2, and we are fine.
But there's a remaining
probability of 0.4
that the true value of Theta
is different than our estimate.
So there's probability 0.4
of having made a mistake.
If, instead of an
estimate equal to 2,
we had chosen an
estimate equal to 3,
then the true parameter would
be equal to our estimate
with probability 0.3, but
we would have made an error
with probability
0.7, which would
be a bigger
probability of error.
More generally, the
probability of error
of a particular
estimate is the sum
of the probabilities of
the other values of Theta.
And if we want to keep the
probability of error small,
we want to keep the sum
of the probabilities
of the other values
small, which means
we want to pick an estimate for
which its own probability is
large.
And so by that argument,
we see that the way
to achieve the smallest
possible probability of error
is to employ the MAP rule.
This is a very important
property of the MAP rule.
Now, this is the
conditional probability
of error, given that we
already have data in our hands.
But more generally, we may want
to compare estimators or talk
about their performance in terms
of their overall probability
of error.
We're designing a
decision-making system
that's going to process
data and making decisions.
In order to say how
good our system is,
we want to say that overall,
whenever you use the system,
there's going to be
some random parameter,
there's going to be some
value of the estimate.
And we want to know what's the
probability that these two will
be different.
We can calculate this
overall probability of error
by using the total
probability theorem.
And the conditional
probabilities of error as
follows.
We condition on the value of
X. For any possible value of X,
we have a conditional
probability of error.
And then we take
a weighted average
of these conditional
probabilities of error.
There's also an alternative way
of using the total probability
theorem, which would be to
first condition on Theta
and calculate the conditional
probability of error
for a given choice of
this unknown parameter.
And both of these
formulas can be used.
Which one of the two
is more convenient
really depends on the
specifics of the problem.
Finally, I would like to make
an important observation.
We argued that for
any particular choice
of an observation, the MAP
rule achieves the smallest
possible probability of error.
So under the MAP rule,
this term is as small
as possible for any given
value of the random variable,
capital X.
Since each term of this
sum is as small as possible
under the MAP rule, it means
that the overall sum will also
be as small as possible.
And this means is that the
overall probability of error
is also smallest
under the MAP rule.
In this sense, the MAP
rule is the optimum way
of coming up with estimates in
the hypothesis-testing context,
where we want to minimize
the probability of error.